This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. On the border of Virginia and North Carolina near the eastern shoreline, stretches a great Dismulswamp. The great Dismulswamp actually, that's the name British colonists have given it by the early 1700s. The swamp covers about 190 square miles today, but at its peak before parts of it were drained and developed, it was around 10 times bigger, spanning roughly 2000 square miles of Virginia and North Carolina. That's our own Sharifusive.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。在弗吉尼亚州和北卡罗来纳州的边界，靠近东海岸线的地方，延伸着一片巨大的“阴郁沼泽”（Great Dismal Swamp）。事实上，“阴郁沼泽”这个名字是英国殖民者在18世纪初给它起的。如今，这片沼泽占地约190平方英里，但在它被排干和开发之前，其巅峰时期的面积大约是现在的10倍，横跨弗吉尼亚州和北卡罗来纳州约2000平方英里。这是我们的谢里夫·尤瑟夫。
And it's understandable why people call the swamp dismal. Temperatures can reach over 100 degrees. It's humid and soggy, filled with thorns and thickets. Oh, yes. It is quite dismal, they named it, I think, somewhat appropriately. That's Eric Shepard. He lives in Carrollton, Virginia, and he runs a company that leads tourists to the Great Dismiss Whomp, which is teaming with all sorts of dangerous and unpleasant wildlife. You still have black bear and some of the poisonous snakes and yellow flies and mosquitoes. I mean, you still have the hazards there in the swamp.
人们称这片沼泽为“阴郁”是有原因的。气温可以达到华氏100度以上。这里潮湿泥泞，长满了荆棘和灌木丛。哦，是的。它确实非常阴郁，我想他们起这个名字相当贴切。这是埃里克·谢泼德。他住在弗吉尼亚州的卡罗尔顿，经营着一家带领游客前往“阴郁沼泽”的公司，那里到处都是各种危险且令人不快的野生动物。你仍然会遇到黑熊、一些毒蛇、黄蝇和蚊子。我的意思是，沼泽里依然存在这些危险。
And even if you go in with a compass and a map, it's easy to get lost. But hundreds of years ago, before the Civil War, the dangers of the swamp and its seeming impenetrability actually attracted a lot of people, including one of Shepherd's ancestors who was enslaved in the region. I've read information that approximately 50,000 escaped Africans went through and or lived in the dismal swamp. That's a lot of people to come through there.
即使你带着指南针和地图进去，也很容易迷路。但在几百年前，内战之前，沼泽的危险及其看似无法逾越的特性实际上吸引了很多人，包括谢泼德的一位祖先，他曾在该地区被奴役。我读过资料，大约有5万名逃亡的非洲人穿过或居住在阴郁沼泽中。有这么多人经过那里。
Despite all its predators and bugs, all its thorns and vines, all its dismalness and swampiness, this land was home to generations of people. It was the site of one of the most remarkable and least told stories of resistance to slavery in the United States. African-Americans set up communities in their swamp, and they were protected there, but they were also
尽管有各种掠食者和虫子，所有的荆棘和藤蔓，所有的阴郁和泥泞，但这片土地却是几代人的家园。它是美国反抗奴隶制最引人注目且鲜为人知的故事之一的发生地。非裔美国人在沼泽中建立了社区，他们在那里受到保护，但他们也
in a state of empowerment that they were not going to let anybody come there and move them out of their community in their swamp. References to the Great Dismissed Swamp and the escape slaves who settled there started appearing in newspapers and other sources in the 1700s, but archaeologists have found evidence that people were living in the swamp long before that. When you look at 1607 all the way to about 1660, I believe that the major group of people that were coming into that swamp interior were indigenous Americans.
处于一种赋权的状态，他们不会让任何人来到那里，把他们从沼泽的社区中赶走。关于“阴郁沼泽”以及定居在那里的逃亡奴隶的记载，从18世纪开始出现在报纸和其他资料中，但考古学家发现证据表明，早在那个时候，人们就已经在沼泽中生活了。当你审视从1607年一直到1660年左右的这段时间，我相信进入沼泽内部的主要群体是美洲原住民。
That's Professor Dan Sayers, an historical archaeologist in American University, and a leading expert on the Great Dismissed Swamp. Sayers says that these indigenous Americans were seeking refuge from European settlers who'd started building colonies up and down the eastern coast of America. As colonialism sort of expanded and intensified and the landscape developed into the ranches
那是丹·塞耶斯教授，他是美利坚大学的历史考古学家，也是“阴郁沼泽”的顶尖专家。塞耶斯说，这些美洲原住民是为了躲避欧洲定居者，因为这些定居者开始在美国东海岸沿线建立殖民地。随着殖民主义的扩张和加剧，景观被开发成牧场
and the farms and the plantations and all the stuff, we were sort of familiar with that swamp, it was just sort of this untamed place. Then around 1700 or so, the demographics of the swamp started to shift. By that time, slavery was widespread in the American colonies, and when enslaved people escaped, the swamp was an obvious place to hide out. News of the swamp probably spread quietly through word of mouth. Probably an underground sort of great vibe that people learned this when they were
农场、种植园以及所有那些我们比较熟悉的东西，那片沼泽只是一个未被驯服的地方。然后在大约1700年左右，沼泽的人口结构开始发生变化。到那时，奴隶制在美国殖民地已经非常普遍，当被奴役的人逃跑时，沼泽是一个显而易见的藏身之处。关于沼泽的消息可能通过口口相传悄悄传播开来。可能是一种地下的、很棒的氛围，人们在他们
trustworthy enough they learned the information of how to go into the swamp and then find these resistance communities. The escape slaves who found refuge in the swamp came to be known as maroons from the Spanish word simaran meaning wild or untamed. Unlike some other runaways who had a de-Northern cities, maroons lived in the wilderness, and difficult to reach places. They were determined to build their own communities,
足够值得信任时，学会了如何进入沼泽并找到这些反抗社区的信息。在沼泽中找到避难所的逃亡奴隶被称为“马龙人”（maroons），源自西班牙语“simarrón”，意为“野生的”或“未驯服的”。与那些前往北方城市的逃亡者不同，马龙人生活在荒野和难以到达的地方。他们决心建立自己的社区，
with the forces of nature and landscape serving as a buffer between their new lives and the society that enslaved them. This is thousands of African-Americans who totally, totally created their own world and successfully gave the bird as it were, right? To that outside world, that capitalistic world, that enslaving world. Sayers has spent years going into the swamp and surveying it.
以大自然的力量和地形作为他们新生活与奴役他们的社会之间的缓冲。这是成千上万的非裔美国人，他们完全、彻底地创造了自己的世界，并成功地向那个外部世界、那个资本主义世界、那个奴役世界竖起了中指，对吧？塞耶斯花了很多年时间进入沼泽并对其进行勘测。
It's quite a journey for participants in this project. This tape is from a short film about the dismaswamp called Landscape of Power by Nina Shapiro-Purro. Over time, savers has come to love this dismal terrain. It's all just a wonderful thing to walk around out there in the thick of it. And out there, in the thick of it, emerging from the dark brown waters. All of a sudden, you come upon a little plot of dry ground islands, and they're pretty good size, in many cases, like 20, 30, 40 acres, and they just sort of sporadically pop up. It was on these islands that maroon communities formed, likely a few dozen people on each one,
对于这个项目的参与者来说，这是一段非凡的旅程。这段录音来自一部关于阴郁沼泽的短片，由尼娜·夏皮罗-珀罗制作，名为《权力的景观》。随着时间的推移，塞耶斯开始爱上这片阴郁的地形。在茂密的丛林中走来走去，这真是一件美妙的事情。在茂密的丛林中，从深褐色的水中浮现出来。突然，你会发现一小块干燥的土地——岛屿，它们通常相当大，很多情况下有20、30、40英亩，它们只是零星地出现。正是在这些岛屿上，马龙人社区形成了，每个岛上可能有几十人，
with some ingling and trade happening between the islands that were close together. And based on archaeological evidence, Sayers has pieced together an idea of what their lives might have looked like. To shelter themselves, the maroons built elevated cabins that they lifted above the moist ground using wooden posts. Sayers knows this because the wood that they used to build the structures has changed the color of the soil
相邻的岛屿之间会有一些交流和贸易。根据考古证据，塞耶斯拼凑出了他们生活样貌的构想。为了遮风挡雨，马龙人建造了高脚屋，利用木桩将房屋架在潮湿的地面之上。塞耶斯之所以知道这一点，是因为他们用来建造结构的木材改变了土壤的颜色。
So the post-Rots in place and it looks much darker contrasting with that usually lighter soil around it and the maroons grew food to support themselves They probably almost certainly Cultivated sort of community grain and rice fields out in the swamp I think they did community labor communal labor like that, gathering not only what they ate on a daily basis, but probably some of the surplus is to to store for winter and hard times. But forming this picture of life in the swamp hasn't been easy because most evidence of the maroons has long vanished. All the organic stuff that these communities used and created, how to trees, wood, plant materials, whatever, that's all long-rided away, so we unfortunately lost what probably is about 90% or more of what they used on a daily basis.
所以木桩在原地腐烂，看起来比周围通常较浅的土壤颜色深得多。马龙人种植粮食来维持生计。他们几乎肯定在沼泽中开垦了社区谷物和稻田。我认为他们进行了社区劳动，像那样的集体劳动，不仅收集他们日常食用的东西，可能还有一些剩余的粮食来储存以备过冬和困难时期。但是，勾勒出沼泽中的生活图景并不容易，因为马龙人的大部分证据早已消失。这些社区使用和创造的所有有机材料，如树木、木材、植物材料等等，早已腐烂殆尽，所以我们不幸丢失了他们日常生活中所使用物品的90%以上。
Sears says that normally at other sites from this period, you'd find a bunch of mass-produced goods, like glass containers and lead shot and tobacco pipes. But there's not much of that stuff in the swamp. The dearth of these goods speaks to how self-sufficient the maroons were. There wasn't much from the outside world coming in. So what they're doing is it's like, okay, no, our goal is to settle the swamp and this is our world. Instead of a bunch of intact artifacts, saires and his team have found tiny bits and
塞耶斯说，通常在这一时期的其他遗址中，你会发现大量批量生产的商品，如玻璃容器、铅弹和烟斗。但在沼泽中，这类东西并不多。这些物品的匮乏说明了马龙人是多么自给自足。来自外部世界的东西并不多。所以他们的做法就像是，好吧，不，我们的目标是定居在沼泽里，这就是我们的世界。塞耶斯和他的团队没有发现大量完整的文物，而是发现了微小的碎片和
pieces of old stone tools, which maroons found or inherited from previous Native American inhabitants. At one excavation site, for example, they found 5,000 such artifacts, and even though that sounds like a lot, Sayers says he could fit them all into a shoe box. Sayers research suggests that at its peak, from around 1750 to right before the Civil War, the dismal swamp was home to thousands of self-sufficient maroons, and it also served as a stopping point for other escape slaves who were fleeing north on the underground railroad. But like most maroon communities, it was under constant threat of discovery. The great Dismisswomp is not the only example of a maroon settlement, far from it.
旧石器工具的残片，这些是马龙人发现或从之前的印第安原住民那里继承来的。例如，在一个挖掘点，他们发现了5000件这样的文物，尽管听起来很多，但塞耶斯说他可以把它们全部装进一个鞋盒里。塞耶斯的调查显示，在巅峰时期，即从1750年左右到内战前夕，阴郁沼泽居住着成千上万自给自足的马龙人，它也成为了通过“地下铁路”向北逃亡的其他奴隶的中转站。但像大多数马龙人社区一样，它一直处于被发现的持续威胁之下。“阴郁沼泽”并不是马龙人定居点的唯一例子，远非如此。
Wherever slavery existed, there were runaways who escaped to live in the wilderness. That means there were maroons in the British colonies, in Spanish and Portuguese colonies, and then in the newly independent countries and states that those colonies gave birth to. In some cases, maroons clashed with colonial forces, like in Jamaica, where they fought wars against the British and negotiated treaties to stay in their communities. In fact, there's a settlement in Jamaica where descendants of maroons still live, a place called Morton, tucked away high in the country's eastern mountains. In the US, maroon communities existed all across the South,
无论奴隶制存在的地方，都有逃亡者逃往荒野生活。这意味着在英国殖民地、西班牙和葡萄牙殖民地，以及这些殖民地诞生后的新独立国家和州中，都有马龙人。在某些情况下，马龙人与殖民势力发生冲突，比如在牙买加，他们与英国人作战并谈判签署条约以留在他们的社区中。事实上，在牙买加有一个定居点，马龙人的后裔至今仍住在那里，一个叫莫顿的地方，隐藏在该国东部的高山中。在美国，马龙人社区遍布南方，
and the North, and even in Western states, like Texas. This is from an interview with a former slave named Laura Smalley. It was recorded in 1941. She talks about what it was like growing up and working on a plantation in Belleville, Texas. The interviewer asks, what did the slaves ever try to slip away? They ever try to run off.
北方，甚至在德克萨斯州等西部各州也有存在。这段录音来自对一位名叫劳拉·斯马利的昔日奴隶的采访。它录制于1941年。她谈到了在德克萨斯州贝尔维尔的种植园长大和工作的经历。采访者问，奴隶们是否曾经试图溜走？他们是否曾经试图逃跑？
And she replies, now I heard Mama say when she was a girl, that one old woman run off, and every night she slipped home and somebody had for something to eat and she get that bills and going back in the woods, going back staying in the woods. That's once his man stayed in the woods so long, tell you just how long he longed like a dog, you know, and stayed in the woods, and stayed in the woods. And they couldn't get them out. Stay in the woods, I ain't got long stay.
她回答说，我听妈妈说，当她还是个女孩的时候，有一个老妇人跑了，每天晚上她都溜回家，有人给她点吃的，她就拿上那些东西回到树林里，回到树林里待着。那个人在树林里待了太久，告诉你他待了多久，像狗一样叫，你知道，待在树林里，一直待在树林里。他们无法把她弄出来。待在树林里，我不会待太久。
Cause the cold in me ain't got long stay. Lord, I ain't got long stay in the woods, I ain't got long stay. Every maroon community across the country was unique. Some maroons lived in the woods, like the woman and man described by Smolly. Others lived in the mountains or swamps. Some even lived in underground shelters that they dug out in wild areas near plantations. So in those little caves or dens, as they sometimes call them as well, you sometimes add a real house, some at furniture, some add stoves.
因为寒冷，我不会待太久。上帝啊，我不会在树林里待太久，我不会待太久。全国各地的每一个马龙人社区都是独特的。一些马龙人住在树林里，就像斯马利描述的那个女人和男人一样。其他人住在山里或沼泽里。有些人甚至住在他们自己在种植园附近的荒野地区挖出的地下掩体中。所以，在那些小洞穴或巢穴里，正如他们有时称呼的那样，你有时会发现真正的房子，有的有家具，有的有炉子。
This is Dr. Sylvie Ann DeUuff, a historian of the African diaspora and author of Slavery's Exiles, the story of the American Maroons. She says that these subterranean maroon shelters were often ingeniously constructed. Some had timber-supported roofs, complete with trapped doors that had all traces of their presence. That trap, which opened on the outside, had to be camouflage to the point that it would be invisible, but it would also be studied enough
这是西尔维·安·德乌夫博士，她是非洲侨民历史学家，也是《奴隶的流亡：美国马龙人的故事》一书的作者。她说，这些地下的马龙人掩体通常建造得非常巧妙。有些有木材支撑的屋顶，配有活板门，掩盖了他们存在的所有痕迹。那个向外打开的活板门必须伪装到看不出来的程度，但它也必须足够坚固，
that if somebody would stand on it, they wouldn't cave in. Some shelters even had systems of wooden pipes that transported the stove smoke away from the maroon stands so it wouldn't give away their location. Broadly, do you have found that most maroons tended to live in one of two types of places, each with its own advantages? Some resided on the borders of plantations.
以至于如果有人站在上面，它也不会塌陷。一些掩体甚至有木管系统，将炉子的烟雾输送到远离马龙人藏身处的地方，这样就不会暴露他们的位置。总的来说，你发现大多数马龙人倾向于住在两种地方之一，每种地方都有其自身的优势？一些人住在种植园的边缘。
Where their family and friends lived, and so they would go back at night, you know, just to be with them, to get news, and also to gather intelligence. Are the maroons chose to live more removed from civilization in the hinterlands? The hinterlands, the main feature is that they were secluded, they were difficult to access. But wherever they were, the maroons all had something in common. They wanted freedom, yes, but even more, they wanted autonomy, a kind of control over their lives that wouldn't be possible
他们的家人和朋友住在那里，所以他们晚上会回去，你知道，只是为了和他们在一起，获取新闻，也为了收集情报。另一些马龙人选择住在远离文明的腹地。腹地的主要特点是它们与世隔绝，难以进入。但无论他们在哪里，马龙人都有一个共同点。他们想要自由，是的，但更重要的是，他们想要自主权，一种在北方即使作为自由黑人也不可能实现的对自己生活的控制。
even as free black people in the North. The maroons were self-rulled, whether as individuals or families or community. They felt safer in the woods and the swamps, even though it was a hard life, full of danger, but they felt safer among adigators that among white people. In the late 1700s, white people were rapidly becoming a greater threat than the reptiles
马龙人是自治的，无论是作为个人、家庭还是社区。他们觉得在树林和沼泽里更安全，尽管那是一种充满危险的艰苦生活，但他们觉得在短吻鳄中间比在白人中间更安全。在18世纪末，白人迅速成为比“阴郁沼泽”的爬行动物更大的威胁。
of the Great Dismiss Whomp. As more and more Europeans arrived in the area, land grew scarce and more valuable. Wealthy colonists saw economic opportunity in developing a swamp. In 1763, a young George Washington, yeah, that George Washington, and his brother John started accompanying with a goal of saving, improving, that George Washington, and his brother John started a company with the goal of saving, improving, and draining the land. George Washington, the original Swamp Trainer. Eventually, their company and others would create a network of canals so that boats could
随着越来越多的欧洲人来到该地区，土地变得稀缺且更有价值。富有的殖民者看到了开发沼泽的经济机会。1763年，年轻的乔治·华盛顿——没错，就是那个乔治·华盛顿，和他的兄弟约翰成立了一家公司，目标是拯救、改善和排干这片土地。乔治·华盛顿，最初的沼泽排干者。最终，他们的公司和其他公司将建立一个运河网络，以便船只可以
go into the swamp. Of course, they used slave labor for all of this. Here's Dan Sayers again. We see suddenly an introduction of a whole new, large group of people enslaved workers, right? For our broadened by these companies to help begin transforming the swamp. By the early 1800s, Tracts of Land had been clear to trees, and parts of the once impenetrable region had been opened up to new people and industries. But remember, the swamp is still huge.
进入沼泽。当然，他们为此使用了奴隶劳动。这是丹·塞耶斯。我们突然看到了一大群新人的引入——被奴役的工人，对吧？被这些公司带到这里，开始帮助改造沼泽。到19世纪初，大片土地的树木被砍伐，曾经无法逾越的地区的一部分被向新的人群和工业开放。但请记住，沼泽依然巨大。
If maroons didn't want to engage with that encroaching world, they could still find places removed from the industry's presence, even as that presence became more permanent. Timber companies set up encampments in the swamp for enslaved workers who were sent in to cut down trees. They turned that lumber into shingles and shipped them all over the region. Which brings us back to Eric Shepherd, the tour guide we heard from at the beginning of the story, whose ancestors spent time in the swamp. I believe he was my great, great grandfather's uncle. His name was Moses Grandy. And he was enslaved down in Camden County,
如果马龙人不想与那个不断侵入的世界接触，他们仍然可以找到远离工业存在的地方，即使这种存在变得更加永久。木材公司在沼泽中为被送去砍伐树木的奴隶工人建立了营地。他们把木材变成木瓦，并运往该地区各地。这让我们回到了埃里克·谢泼德，我们在故事开头听到的那位导游，他的祖先曾在沼泽中度过时光。我相信他是我的高祖父的叔叔。他的名字叫摩西·格兰迪。他曾在卡姆登县被奴役，
North Carolina, born in 1786. Grandy was a skilled boat captain, and his talents were highly sought after in the canals of the Great Dismissed Swamp. He was a water man that delivered those shingles to the Norfolk area so they could build houses. While Grandy was working in the swamp. It's likely that he got to know some of the maroons who lived there. While some maroons remained isolated in their communities, others saw opportunities with the new timber industry. Contact between enslaved workers and the maroons who lived near the new timber camps became pretty common.
北卡罗来纳州，出生于1786年。格兰迪是一位熟练的船长，他的才华在“阴郁沼泽”的运河中备受追捧。他是一名水手，负责将那些木瓦运送到诺福克地区，以便他们建造房屋。当格兰迪在沼泽工作时，他很可能认识了一些住在那里马龙人。虽然一些马龙人仍然孤立在他们的社区中，但其他人看到了新木材工业带来的机会。被奴役的工人和住在新木材营地附近的马龙人之间的接触变得相当普遍。
Sometimes maroons would help workers with shingle production and exchange for goods from the outside world. But one day during his time on the canals, Grandi fell ill, a case of severe rheumatism. And when he needed a place to recover, he picked the swamp. He ended up living in the swamp for a whole year. Shepard thinks he must have had people he could depend on. I don't think you just do that and not know anybody in that swamp. You knew some people there they watched out for you and over the course of years I'm sure that Moses watched out for them. In a narrative later published about Moses' grandies life, he described his time in the swamp, read here by our friend, I'll let's him.
有时马龙人会帮助工人生产木瓦，以换取来自外部世界的商品。但有一天，在运河工作期间，格兰迪病倒了，患上了严重的风湿病。当他需要一个地方康复时，他选择了沼泽。他最终在沼泽里住了一整年。谢泼德认为他一定有可以依赖的人。我不认为你只是那样做而不认识沼泽里的任何人。你认识那里的一些人，他们照顾你，我相信多年来，摩西也照顾了他们。在后来出版的关于摩西·格兰迪生平的叙述中，他描述了他在沼泽中的时光，由我们的朋友阿尔·莱森朗读。
I built myself a little hut and had provisions brought to me as opportunity served. Here, among the snakes, bears, and panthers, whenever my strength was sufficient, I cut down a juniper tree and converted it into Koopas timber. One night, I was awoke by a large animal smelling my face sniffing strongly. I felt this cold muzzle. I suddenly thrust out my arms and shot it with all my might. It was frightened and made off. I put my trust in Lord and continued on the spot. I was never attacked again."
“我给自己盖了一个小屋，并按机会把补给品带给我。在这里，在蛇、熊和美洲狮中间，只要我的体力足够，我就砍下一棵杜松树，把它做成木桶木材。一天晚上，我被一只大动物吵醒，它闻着我的脸，嗅得很厉害。我感觉到这冰冷的口鼻。我突然伸出双臂，用尽全力射击它。它被吓跑了。我把我的信任寄托在上帝身上，并继续留在原地。我再也没有受到攻击。”
Eventually, Grandi recovered and went back to work. In an 1833, he managed to buy his freedom. He became part of the abolitionist movement. In travel to Europe, Marie spoke out against what he'd seen and experienced. And his narrative, Randy reflected on what it meant to be free after so many years of enslavement. I felt myself so light that almost thought I could fly. And in my sleep, I was always dreaming of flying over woods and rivers. My gate was so old to buy my gladness and people often
最终，格兰迪康复并回去工作。1833年，他设法买回了自己的自由。他成为了废奴运动的一部分。在前往欧洲旅行时，格兰迪公开反对他所见所闻的一切。在他的叙述中，格兰迪反思了在经历了这么多年的奴役后获得自由意味着什么。“我感到自己如此轻盈，几乎以为自己能飞。在睡梦中，我总是梦见飞越树林和河流。我的步态因我的喜悦而变得如此轻快，人们经常
stopped me saying, Grandet, what's the matter? Slavery will teach any man to be glad when he gets his freedom. From what researchers can tell, Maroon communities in the states existed as long as they were necessary or as long as they remained hidden from the outside world. Dan Sayers thinks that the communities in the Great Dismisswomp began to disperse around the time of the Civil War. My impression based on the evidence from one interior site right now is that somewhere more or less coincident with the Mancipation Proclamation, these communities finally
拦住我说，‘格兰迪，怎么了？’奴隶制会教会任何人在获得自由时感到高兴。”据研究人员所知，美国的马龙人社区只要有必要，或者只要他们能躲避外部世界，就会一直存在。丹·塞耶斯认为，“阴郁沼泽”中的社区在内战前后开始分散。根据目前一个内部遗址的证据，我的印象是，在《解放黑人奴隶宣言》发布的同时，这些社区最终
disbanded. Some maroons left to join the Union in battle, and after the war, some may have gone looking for newly freed family in the South. Some may have traveled north, some may have settled in neighboring towns. Now, one really knows for certain, many enslaved people weren't allowed to read or write, so personal accounts for maroons are rare. It's only in the past few decades that researchers have started to study most US maroon communities in any sort of depth. For a long time, it was barely a footnote in US history.
解散了。一些马龙人离开去参加联邦军队的战斗，战后，一些人可能去南方寻找刚获得自由的家人。一些人可能去了北方，一些人可能在邻近的城镇定居。现在，没有人能确定，许多被奴役的人不被允许阅读或写作，所以马龙人的个人叙述很少。直到过去几十年，研究人员才开始对大多数美国马龙人社区进行任何深入的研究。很长一段时间里，这在美国历史上几乎只是一个脚注。
And one reason for this omission is likely because these communities were intentionally secretive. But some academics think there's a bigger reason why the stories of maroons aren't told. I think in this case you have a good amount of racism, um, that, that sort of, coach, sort of people's understandings of history. Most Americans learn about the underground railroad way back in elementary school. A resistance to slavery that came about through white and black cooperation. The dismal swamp and other maroon communities are all about black autonomy, a complete
这种遗漏的一个原因很可能是因为这些社区是有意保密的。但一些学者认为，马龙人的故事没有被讲述还有一个更大的原因。我认为在这种情况下，你有相当多的种族主义，嗯，这在某种程度上影响了人们对历史的理解。大多数美国人在小学时就了解了“地下铁路”。那是一种通过白人和黑人合作实现的对奴隶制的反抗。“阴郁沼泽”和其他马龙人社区完全是关于黑人的自主权，是对白人社会的彻底
rejection of white society. Here's Sylvie and D, again. I think that the idea of black people taking their lives into their own hands, not wanting to be any part of the larger community, not wanting to be, quote, unquote, free blacks in the North, or pass for free in the sub-being self-ruled, and living their own kind of freedom that was not part of the larger discourse of this country. I think we still have a ways to go in this country to be quite honest with you in terms
拒绝。这是西尔维·安·德乌夫。我认为黑人将自己的生活掌握在自己手中，不想成为更大社区的一部分，不想成为所谓的北方“自由黑人”，或者在南方冒充自由人，而是自我管理，过着他们自己那种不属于这个国家更大话语体系的自由生活，这种想法。老实说，我认为我们在历史方面还有很长的路要走，
of history, uncut, and raw. That's one of the reasons Eric Shepard started his tour company. He wants more people to know the history. He left behind a good government job in Baltimore and he and his wife moved to southern Virginia. Just to be closer to the hot, muggy, dismal swamp. I felt as though it was a calling, there was an assignment, there was a need for me to be down in this area like it was some unfinished business for whatever reason. In 2003, several sites in the Great Dismul Swamp were added to the National Parks Service Network to Freedom, which recognizes 400 locations involved in the Underground Railroad.
未经过滤且原始的历史。这就是埃里克·谢泼德创办他的旅游公司的原因之一。他希望更多的人了解这段历史。他放弃了巴尔的摩一份不错的工作，和妻子搬到了弗吉尼亚州南部。只是为了离炎热、潮湿、阴郁的沼泽更近一点。我觉得这是一种召唤，有一个任务，我需要在这个地区，就像因为某种原因有一些未完成的事情。2003年，“阴郁沼泽”的几个遗址被加入到国家公园管理局的“自由网络”中，该网络认可了400个参与“地下铁路”的地点。
And, a sign at the Great Dismul Swamp recognizes that this place wasn't just a stop for people on the underground railroad. There were entire communities of people who made this their permanent home. Today the largest remaining part of the Great Dismal Swamp is a national refuge stewarded by the U.S. Fish and Wildlife Service, who aimed to protect the wildlife that's made a home there, and to preserve its unique landscape, keeping alive the memory of the people who found refuge in its dismal terrain.
而且，“阴郁沼泽”的一块标志牌承认，这个地方不仅仅是“地下铁路”上人们的一个中转站。有整个社区的人把这里当作他们永久的家。今天，阴郁沼泽最大的剩余部分是一个国家保护区，由美国鱼类及野生动物管理局管理，他们旨在保护在那里安家的野生动物，并保护其独特的景观，让那些在阴郁地形中找到避难所的人们的记忆得以延续。
It is a strong and rich history, which should be acknowledged, and we are very proud of our ancestors that endured, that hell here on earth. Among the Black Bear, in Panthers, the rattlesnakes and moccasins, even the unrelenting mosquitoes, the very habitat whose dangers allowed thousands of people to live in relative peace on their own terms. We'll share a little gem of an outtake from Shree's research of this piece after this. Hey, it's Shree here. As I was making this story, I read in Silvian News book that the WPA, the Works Progress Administration, did this project called Voices From the Days of
这是一段强大而丰富的历史，应该得到承认，我们为我们的祖先感到非常自豪，他们忍受了人间地狱。在黑熊、美洲狮、响尾蛇和棉口蛇，甚至无情的蚊子中间，正是这种栖息地的危险，让成千上万的人能够按照自己的方式相对和平地生活。我们将在之后分享一点谢里夫研究这段内容的幕后花絮。嘿，我是谢里夫。在制作这个故事时，我在西尔维·安·德乌夫的书里读到，WPA（公共事业振兴署）做了一个名为“奴隶时代的声音”的项目。
Slavery. That's where I found the tape of Laura Smalley, who you heard from in the episode. And in going through all those interviews, I found this song that's been stuck in my head and I wanted to share it. On the Library of Congress website, it says it's part of an interview with Wallace Cordenerman, recorded in Georgia in 1935, but there are several voices in it. We're not quite sure who they all are, but is it really good song so yeah hope you liked it And hear the fount of peace, when the f that He is the time of the Lord. So let me tell you about the town of one. The Lord's Lord wake and just be drunk. So let me tell you about the town of two.
我在那里找到了劳拉·斯马利的录音，你在这一集中听到了。在翻阅所有这些采访时，我发现了这首歌，它一直在我脑海中挥之不去，我想分享它。在国会图书馆的网站上，它说这是1935年在佐治亚州录制的对华莱士·科登曼采访的一部分，但里面有几个声音。我们不太确定他们都是谁，但这真的是一首好歌，所以希望你喜欢。这是上帝的时间。所以让我告诉你关于一号城镇的事。上帝的上帝醒着，只是喝醉了。所以让我告诉你关于二号城镇的事。
The Lord's Lord is private too. So this voice is from the Days of Slavery project has a lot of really incredible tape. If you want to hear more, just google WPA Voices of Slavery and you'll be able to find them. They're hosted on the Library of Congress website. say. 99% of visible was produced this week by Shereefusef, with editing by Delaney Hall. Katie Mingle is our senior producer, Kurt Colstead is the digital director. Sean Rial composed the music. The rest of the staff includes Emmett Fitzgerald, Avery Trouffman, Teran Mazza, and me, Roman Mars. Additional music this week by our pal, Ok Akumi.
上帝的上帝也是私人的。所以这个来自“奴隶时代的声音”项目的声音有很多非常不可思议的录音。如果你想听更多，只需谷歌搜索“WPA Voices of Slavery”，你就能找到它们。它们托管在国会图书馆的网站上。《99%隐形》本周由谢里夫·尤瑟夫制作，德莱尼·霍尔编辑。凯蒂·明格尔是我们的高级制作人，库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。肖恩·里亚尔创作了音乐。其余工作人员包括埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼、特兰·马扎，以及我，罗曼·马斯。本周的额外音乐由我们的朋友奥克·阿库米提供。
We have links to Sylvie Andie Uff's book, Slavery's Exiles and Dancer's book, A Desolate Place for a Defiant People on our website. Thanks to Nina Shapiro Pearl of American University for the use for short film, Landscape of Power. If you're interested in learning more about tours to the Great Dismiss Womp, check out Eric Shepard's website, diversityrestoration.com. Special thanks also to Terrence Wyke and the Oakland African American Museum in Library. Thanks also to Al Letson of the podcast for Veal, who voiced Moses Grandy.
我们的网站上有西尔维·安·德乌夫的书《奴隶的流亡》和丹·塞耶斯的书《反抗者的荒凉之地》的链接。感谢美利坚大学的尼娜·夏皮罗-珀罗使用她的短片《权力的景观》。如果你有兴趣了解更多关于“阴郁沼泽”的旅游信息，请查看埃里克·谢泼德的网站 diversityrestoration.com。还要特别感谢特伦斯·怀克以及奥克兰非裔美国人博物馆和图书馆。还要感谢播客《Veal》的阿尔·莱森，他为摩西·格兰迪配音。
The archival audio of Laura Smallway was from the WPA's Voices of Slavery Project, hosted by the Library of Congress. This piece was inspired and part by an essay in the Smithsonian magazine by Richard Grant. We'll have links to all this and more on our website. We are a project of radio, Topia and KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in
劳拉·斯马利的档案音频来自WPA的“奴隶的声音”项目，由国会图书馆托管。这篇文章的部分灵感来自理查德·格兰特在《史密森尼》杂志上发表的一篇文章。我们将在我们的网站上提供所有这些内容的链接。我们是旧金山RadioTopia和KALW的一个项目，在Radio Row制作，位于
beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. We are a proud member of Radio Topia from PRX, supported by the night foundation and listeners just like you. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI or grow on Instagram, Tumblr, and you. You're too be on me. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。我们是PRX旗下RadioTopia的骄傲成员，由奈特基金会和像你一样的听众支持。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PI，或者在Instagram、Tumblr上关注我们。你也可以在PRX上找到我们。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。